Tout ça grâce au simple équipement que je vous ai décrit.
Ma femme a réalisé
des essais sur le terrain
pour certains microscopes.
Elle lave mes vêtements
quand je les oublie dans le sèche-linge.
Il s'avère que les microscopes sont imperméables aussi.
(Rires) -
Quand je le plonge dans de l'eau fluorescente,
vous pouvez voir comment fonctionne
le principe de projection.
Vous pouvez voir le rayon
tel qu'il est projeté et diffracté.
Peut-on rallumer les lumières ?
Puisqu'il me reste peu de temps,
je vais vous parler rapidement
du coût de fabrication.
L'idée centrale est de fabriquer à partir de rouleaux.
Nos coûts de production sont de 50 cents.
(Applaudissements)
C'est un nouveau paradigme :
la microscopie jetable.
Je vais vous montrer rapidement
quelques composants.
Voilà une feuille de papier, format A4.
Voilà les trois étapes, très visibles.
Vous voyez les composants optiques en haut à droite.
On a dû développer dans le papier
un système de production de lentilles à haut rendement.
On utilise un processus
d'auto-assemblage et de tension de surface
pour fabriquer des lentilles achromatiques en papier.
Donc, les lentilles vont là.
Il y a des sources de lumière.
Fondamentalement,
tous les composants s'alignent à cause de l'origami.
L'origami permet en effet une incroyable précision
d'alignement des éléments optiques.
Alors même si ça ressemble à un simple jouet,
l'ingénierie que nous appliquons
est vraiment sophistiquée.
Je pourrais aussi vous démontrer
que ces microscopes sont robustes
en le jetant du troisième étage.
Le voici, et il fonctionne toujours.
Les essais de terrain sont notre prochaine étape
Nous commencerons à la fin de l'été.
Nous allons fabriquer des milliers de microscopes.
Ce sera une grande première
de réaliser des tests sur le terrain
avec un nombre record de microscopes
concentrés sur un endroit donné.
Nous avons commencé à recueillir chez des patients
des données sur le paludisme, la maladie de Chagas et le Giarda.
Je vais terminer avec cette image.
C'était tout à fait imprévu
mais nous avons découvert un lien intéressant
entre l'enseignement pratique des sciences
et la santé mondiale.
Quels sont les outils
que nous allons transmettre à nos enfants
afin qu'ils puissent combattre ce bouillon de monstres?
J'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils puissent
imprimer un "Foldscope" pour l'emporter dans leur poche.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)